で 仏教ではそれでも一万六千回終わったらあいつは死んじゃうんだと
その次元に っていうことを言いたがってるんですね
そのため寿量ということを言うんです
死ぬんだと いくら長くたっても
で それでもう一つ インド人はよくブラフマンやらね
そういう神々にお祈りしたり
我々救ってくれてまえとかね
助けてくれてまえとか言ってるんですね
神々に頼る ヒンドゥー教だったら神々よりは修行やらヨーガやっている人々はやっぱり梵天に頼ったりする
まあこれ理想的には梵天に頼らなくちゃいけないんだけど
みんなまあまあ日常的な宗教やってますからね
ヴィシュヌ神やらラーマという
あの本当は神々の世界でいないはずいないはずの神なんです
ラーマっていうのは それは今神にしているんです
ヒンドゥー教で ヘーラーマ
ヘーラーマと言いながら
一生懸命 で ヒンドゥー教ではやっぱり修行して神を体験するはずなんですけど
けど なんで神に祈るかと
ヘーラーマ ヘーラーマとかね
祈ることではいけないと
というのも ヒンドゥー教のそのものの教えなんですけど
結局やっぱり祈る方にしようという風になってしまっちゃうんですね
そこで仏教 またそれにちょっとケチをつけちゃうんですね
で 神々の寿命の長さ見ると
例えば まあこの一つの神の寿命がね
もう まあ神 まあ梵天で考えて一劫年だと
ある梵天 まあ一番近いレベルの梵天は一劫年でしょ
一劫ですから 年ではなくて
一劫寿命が長いということは
その人の一生なんです
それは 我々から見れば長いんであって
その人にとっては まあただのその人の一生なんですね
だから長い短いっていうのは主観的な概念なんですね
犬には十五年というのはもうすごい長い時間なんです
十五年経ったらもうよろよろおじいちゃんでおばあちゃんで
性格もそうでしょ すごい年取った犬の性格っていうのは
人間の八十歳の九十歳のおじいちゃんおばあちゃんの性格とほとんど似ているでしょうに
ですから この人のその生命の寿命だから
一劫っていうのは その梵天にとしては大したことはないんだと
そういうわけで この寿命にも寿量にも劫と使うんです
ですから 人間の百年も寿量の劫だと
寿量劫だと 犬の十五年も寿量劫だと言って
梵天の寿命も一劫だと
その劫の場合は宇宙的な時間で次元で一劫と言うんですね
それで何を言いたがっているかというと
梵天が自分の寿命だから
もう人でも助けてあげようかなと思っちゃうと
もう助けられないほど瞬時にこれで消えてしまうでしょうに
だから地球は現れたんだけど
人間が現れてほんのわずかな時間でしょうに
またほんのわずかな時間で地球上から人間消えちゃうでしょうに
そこで梵天から見ればチカッとかったような
感じの命なんですね 我々の命っていうのは
そこで私たちは誰かにね
ひどい目に遭ったら 神様が来てその人に罰が当たるとかね
我々いいことをしているのか
じゃああなたにご褒美をあげますとかね
そんな余裕も暇も向こうにはないんだと
一日まあ二十四時間あるんだけど
人が神にお祈りするために使う時間時間
時間というのはたった五分とかね
十分とか それぐらいの短いんだから
もしかすると祈りしたかないかも
そこら辺に人がいたかいなかったかも
もうそちらはわからないんです
向こう側が だからそんなくだらないことをやめろということを言わないで言ってるんです
言ったら その人々に対して失礼なことを言ったことになるし
道徳的には悪いことをしたことになるんです
なぜならば 神を恐れて生活する人々が
それなりに正しい生活をしているんです
神様のこと怖くて 人に悪口言わない
人のものは盗まない よく知らない
強要しないとかね いろいろ戒律を守って道徳的な生活をしているんですから
もうそんなことは無意味だよ
あーだこーだとか言わない
言ったところで人間が何やるかわかりませんから
その代わりにもっと違う次元で
まあこれぐらい長いですよと
そこでどう見たっても
神様がほんのちょっと遊んでから
まあ人間の面倒を見てやろうと思っちゃったら
もうもうこっちは人間がいない
ですから この例えば我々知っているこのゾウガメとかね
すごい長い寿命の動物を見たら
ものすごい遅いですよ
行動するのは アリみたいに虫みたいにもう随分早く行動しますかね
虫なんかはもう歩く速さ
すっごい速さであっちこっち歩いて交尾して卵産んでもう子供作って年取って死んじゃうんです
みるみるうちに ゾウガメなんかどうですかね
動きがしない 足を本当にゆっくりと
もう食べる時もそんなもんで
で なぜかというと そちらの寿命が長いんだから
まあそのペースになっちゃうんです
だから寿命短いやつらはもうすごい早く行動する
心臓の鼓動を数えて なんかどうかテレビ番組あったんだけど
この寿命が長ければ長いほど心臓が動く数があの 分間に遅いんですね
分間にものすごい早い回数鼓動しちゃうと
寿命もその分で短いだと
ということは 一生で何回心臓ある動物の場合だけなんですけどね
一生何回心臓鼓動するかっていうことは
なんか決まってるような感じで
早く早く動くと その分寿命が短くて
ゆっくり動くとその分寿命が長くなるというふうな
まあなんとなく数時的に結論はテレビで見たんだけど
だからゾウガメは遅いんです
遅い分は寿命は長いし
そうすると一向ぐらい寿命がある人はかなり遅いと思います
その遅さっていうのは理解できるんです
なぜならば一向って梵天でしょ
禅定状態にいるんだから
サマーディ状態で 何も聞こう見ようとかね
そんな気持ちない サマーディ状態で停止して
じっと静かな気持ちでいるんだから
だからお祈りしたっても無駄です
ですから 自分の面倒を自分で見なさいというのは
はっきりとお釈迦様はいつでも言ってるんですね
自分のことは自分でやりなさいと
自分しかないんだと お金ないんだったら仕事をしろと
神様お金くれと言うなと
で 病気だったらそれなりに運動したり
ご飯食べたり 薬を飲んだりして自分で治せと
それに必要なのは自分には明るい心があって
私の責任は私が持ちますというね
弱気を捨てれば まあそれなりにうまく
誰にも負けなく生きていられるんですね
そういうふうな教えは仏教的な教えで
そういうふうに寿命論を流行ったのは
もしかするとこのまあちょっとこの優しい立場でもう人間の考え方を理解できるような教えをということなんです
だから なんで私そういうことを言うんですかというと
僕らには小さい時からこの仏教の教えやら
その苦の概念やらね まあすごい小さい時から教えられるんだから
で やっぱり頭には永遠な次元ということは
いともバカバカらしいということは
もう最初からインプットされてるんですね
自分で発見する前にも
で どう考えたっても このそういう永遠なことを言ってる人々というのはすごい低次元の世界なんですね
どこかで神がいて その神がどうでも人間とコンタクトを取ったり
喋ったり 怒ったり 嫉妬したり
ああだこうだするすごい感情いっぱい持ってる神々なんですね
ヒンドゥーの神々にしたっても
人間と大した変わりはまるっきりない
喧嘩するわ 嫉妬するわ
色々なんですね ストーリー見れば
時々もう人間よりすごいこの汚い醜いところまでもうやってしまうわとかね
ですから 人間想像している神々っていうのは大体その程度で
そちら辺永遠だというと
あまりにもバカバカらしいわけで
そうじゃなくてもっと停止して
もっと安定した存在のことを考えて
そちらも永遠ではないと仏教では言うんですね
そういうことで そういうことを喋っちゃうと時間なくなりますから
ページのマウシキケッソ
で マウシキカイには禅定つしかないんですね
だから禅定つありますから
その禅定つによってそのその次元で生まれちゃうんですね
クウムヘンという禅定を作った人はクウムヘンイジュクシンで生まれて
それでウブンシンがあって
それであの死んでしまっちゃうんですね
同じところに そこで寿命はすごい長い
マウシキカイのボンテンには体が一応ないんです
ヴィーサティカッパサハッサーニアーユッパマーナ
で二万コウですね あのクウムヘンショーのボンテンには二万コウ
シキムヘンのボンテンには四万コウ
それから何でしたっけ？ムショーウショのボンテンの場合は六万コウとヒソーヒイソーのボンテンには八万四千コウになるんです
この四千が面白いんです
だから二で増やしていって
ですから八万でいいんですけど
ちょっともうまた四千
この八万四千っていうのは
このインドの文化では随分もう何て言いますか
人気のある数字なんです
八万四千 ですからもう一番最高なところに行ったら八万四千光年で終わっちゃう
八万四千といえばもう随分それ以上ないという感じがするんですね
一応八万四千というのはなんとなく感じられる数字なんです
このアサンケイヤっていうのはもう感じられないんですね
体で頭で全然感じが取れないんですね
今このシンボル書くんだからね
十の百四十とか それでわかったような気がする
でもどれぐらいかさっぱりわからないんですね
本当は まあもう現代我々にとっても口だけではね
一千万とかね 平気で言うんだけど
一千万というのはどれぐらいのお金かと全然もう実感まるっきりないでしょうし
一億とかね なんとかと言うでしょうね
ある人に聞いたんだけど
この宝くじなんか当たった人々が
まあ一応銀行にお金が入りますけど
やっぱり一回だけ見せてくださいと言うみたいだそうですね
どれぐらいお金かと  [笑い]それ大変な大仕事で
台車に乗せて何台かに乗せて
この紙束を持ってこなくちゃいけないんです
それで実感が湧いた これぐらいかなと
ですから この数字は使うんだけど
実感はないんですね そこで 8万
8万4000というのは
まあなんとなく実感できるぐらいのことで
よく使う数字なんです
次にこの 15 という番号を振っているところで
パティサンディ・バワンガンチャ・タター・チャワナ・マナサン・エーカメーワ・タテーウェーカ・ヴィサヤンチャ・エーカ・ジャーティアン
イダメッタ・パティサンディ・チャトゥッカンとあるお経ですね
人に一つの生命に生まれる心
それから受分心の心と死ぬ時の心は全く同じものだと
この同じ種類だということなんですね
心はずっと変化しますけど
生まれる瞬間で生まれ現れる心には結晶心というんです
それから何も認識しない時は
結晶心は受分心として生滅変化して流れちゃう
何か認識しようと思ったら受分心が消えて
その代わりに認識心が生まれる
認識が終わったらまた受分心になると
で 死ぬ瞬間でもまた同じ心が生まれると
そこで同じ心ですよと言ったっても
変化しない心ですよという意味ではないんです
心は瞬間で消える 消えて次に違う心が生まれる
それで生まれる 違う心は前の心と似ているだけ
似ているんだから同じ心ですよと言うんです
それで一つの生命の  1個の生命の流れでは
基本的に流れているのは種類の一心の心ですよということを言いたがっているんです
そこを理解すると 魂は同じですよという概念は消えるはずなんです
魂があるんだと誤解しているのは
何かどう見てもどこかで自分が何か同じじゃないかと
何を勉強しても自分は自分じゃないかと
下手な人は何やっても下手であるし
上手な人はもう何やってもそれまだ上手であるし
で そういう風に何かこのずっと自分の一生
自分の何か性格の中で何か隠れて
何か何か同じ部分を流れるように感じっていうのは
大体誰にでもあるもので
そこを見て あ それは 変化しない状態ですよ
魂ですよと誤解しちゃう
そういうわけで この群心という概念が出てあって
同じ心ですよと 同じ心は同じですけど
心っていうのは生滅変化して消えて現れて消えて現れていっちゃいますよね
そこでウッパッティ 決勝についての四種類の説明は終わります
次にゴウロ 業の話 業はカンマと読むんですね
パーリ語でカンマと言うんですけど
だいたいみんなサンスクリト語は一般的に使いますから
このカルマと読むんですね
で それも四つに分けて説明します
で まあ意味は今更言う必要ないんだけど
アビダンマの最初のところで
心の説明のところで説明しましたけど
で 一般的に業と言った途端
我々は悪いことを考えちゃうんですね
でも仏教ではいいことも悪いことも全部業と呼ぶんですね
まずそれを理解しておいて
人が不幸にあったら 一般日本語では業が悪いと
あるいは業が深いとかね
なんとか言っちゃうし
で 不幸なことにあっちゃったら
あんたの業がひどいですよとか全然言わないんですね
でも 幸福も不幸も全部業っていうのは
一般的に仏教でそういうふうに見ておかなきゃいけない
業っていうのは行為ですね
働き だから行為に結果が出るんだという当たり前のことで
まずお釈迦様の時代で考えちゃうんですね
行為に結果があると ですから
業っていうのは行為なんですね
パーリ語で同じ言葉なんですけど
英語で言えば 何でしょうかね
アクティビティですかね
アクションですかね あるいはアクト
アクトでもいいんです
全部この動詞で使えます
行為 で 行為は当然結果が出るんですから
結果のための行為だから
だから行為と結果っていうのは離れないものなんです
私は 例えば石をガラスに当てて投げると
だから石がガラスに触れることとガラスが割れることっていうのは
まあ離れないものなんですね
石がガラスに触れた ガラスが割れたと
それで行為 次に結果 順番で言えば順番があるかないか
ちょっと言いにくいんです
この順番が出てくるのは
このちょっと時間的にずれる時なんですね
本当は石がガラスに触れたと
触れることと同時にガラスが割れるんです
そちらは行為と結果は明確なんです
なぜならば時間の感覚ないんだから
そこであなたがガラスを割ったんですよという場合は
ずいぶん時間の感覚が生まれているんです
たくさんのことを忘れているんですね
いわゆる 例えば零点一秒前で私が石を投げたかもしれません
投げた石がガラスのところまで届くためにも時間がかかる
それの他のいろんな原因によって
いろんな新しい行為が生まれてくるでしょう
そこで その行為の流れをいくらでも考えられるんです
それでガラス 私が割ったんだから
私は責任持たなくちゃいけないんだと
そこでそちらにまた誰かがいて
私に先に石で殴ったとする
そうすると私はその人を殴った
殴ったと 石で まあ石を投げたと
その石がガラスに当ててガラスが割れたとすると
その三番目にこの原因結果を探す人があの人へあなたのせいだからあなたは責任持ちなさいと
僕ではなくて その人にも言うかもしれません
ガラス割れたのはあなたが原因でガラスが割れたんだと
どっち取っても もうあまり
私が割ったと言ったっても正しいし
この私に先に殴った人がガラス割れたことの原因だよと言ってもいいし
そこでどこまででもそうやって考えられるんです
あるいはもう一番短い原因で石がガラスに触れたことで
石やガラスに触れることの同時に同時に割れたんだとと言ってもいいし
だから行為と結果っていうのはそういうふうに考えていただきたいんです
長く伸ばせようと思えばいくらでも伸ばせる
そこで短く時間間隔を短くしようとすれば
同時に起こることまで短くすることもできる
そういうふうに考えることは
因果法則に基づいて考えるものなんですね
だから たった一つの原因で何か起こるということをまたないんです
例えば割れたガラスにも原因があるんですね
割れたということは 例えばガラスはぶら下がって触れる
揺れるようにあるんだと
そこで石が行ったところで
その辺でガラスがちょっと揺れて
ブランコみたいに揺れたならば割れないでしょうに
あるいはガラスはすごい強化ガラスで
何のことなくそのエネルギーは吸収して平気にいることもできるし
あるいはそのガラスははめてはめないで
何かクッションで柔らかいガラスなんですけど
クッションでちょっと支えてあったならば
クッションでエネルギーを吸収してガラスは割れなくなっちゃうし
ですから 石が投げてガラスが割れたというよりは
またいろいろ探せば またもう数えられないほどの原因を見つかっちゃうんですね
だから誰のせいにすればいいんですかね
せいにすると そこら辺は問題なんですね
直接ガラス当てて石を投げた人のせいにするか
その人を怒らせた もうもっと前の人にするか
あるいはその人を怒ったのはまたそれなりのまた原因があったんだから
その人を探すかどうかね
行為結果の行為結果っていうのはそういうふうに考えてほしい
それは因果法則なもので
で まあ複雑なものなんですね
とにかく そこで原因は我々いろいろカテゴリにする
一番近い原因 遠い原因とかね
[背景の物音]あるいはずーっといなくちゃいけない原因
あるいは一回だけで現れて消えても良い原因とか
いろいろあるんです そのそのものによりますけど
例えば種を植えて 何か植木鉢で何か植物を育てようとすると
種を植えることは一回だけの原因なんです
でも種に水がある状態はずーっとなくては
なくてはならない 一回だけではダメなんです
木ができても それでもまだずっと水があってほしい
水が切れたらもう植物は死んでしまう
そこで太陽の熱も必要ですけど
まあそれもそれなりに必要ですね
でも 24時間必要というわけでもないんですね
でもある時間は必要ですと
そこで種を植えることは一回きりの原因
なぜ植物が育てられたかというと
人が種を植えて それから水をあげて
それからちゃんと太陽の光に当たったんだからというふうに言うんだけど
そういう原因 4つまとめたんだと
人が種を植えたと 水をあげたと
だから種と水と それから太陽の熱と 3つだけ考えちゃっても
種を植えたことは一回だけの原因で
水はずっとあってほしい
原因で太陽の光はまあそこそこあってほしい
原因で時間的には三種類がそちらも出てくるんですね
そこで小さな植物が出てほしいという希望が人間になければ
その人は種を植えませんね
それで心の原因も出てくるんです
それはどれぐらいあればいいかと
それまたバラバラ 植物が出てきて
花まで咲いてほしい 実まで出てほしいと思っちゃうと
まあその人はそこまで意識を持っていかなくちゃいけない
種を植えてそれで忘れちゃったら
まあ実りませんだから
で そこでもうわかりますかね
原因と結果と それぞれ時間と時間の間隔とかね
そういう部分も複雑でバラバラであるということ
そこでこちらで業という場合は
全ての行為は業と言わない
これは生命の問題について喋るんだから
心の問題について喋るんだから
心の行為について業というんですね
心の行為といっても まあ生命として行動するんですけど
この行動したがる意志自体が業というんですね
行為は 3つありますね
身口意と 体で行動する言葉
口で言葉 喋る頭で物事を考えるという 3つの行為があるんだけど
その行為自体 業と取らないんです
なぜかというと ただそれだけで結果がいるわけでもないんだから
だから私は手で石を投げたことは業だと言わない
それは行為 なぜ投げたかという私の気持ちがここで行為として扱っているんですね
ですから 業っていうのはチェータナですね
チェータナ チェータナっていうのは意志です
そこら辺もいろんな概念ごちゃ混ぜだから
業っていうのはもうなかなか簡単に理解できるものではないんです
お釈迦様はわざと 業と行為っていうのはわざとごちゃ混ぜにしているんです
明確に この宗教で言ってるような運命論とか業論とかね
もうお話ししようとはしなかったんです
それはもう普通の科学的な行為論と混ぜた
それでも分からなくなる
分からなくなることは考えてるんです
やたらに分かったそうとか言うなと
それ全部分かった上で喋ればいいんですね
インドで発達してきた業というのは
やっぱり道徳に関わりますね
結局は 道徳に関わらないと別にもうそんなに気にする必要はないんです
道徳に関わるっていうことは
このやっぱりやってもいい行為とやってはならない行為というふうに二つ現れるということですね
道徳というのはそういうものだから
道徳と倫理学っていうのはね
善と悪の勉強は倫理学だから
まあやってもいい行為とやってはならない行為というふうに
二つに人間の行動パターンを分けて
人間がやってもいいという行動パターンの方にまあ押し付けると
そういうことで 業っていうのは道徳と密接に関係があるようになるんです
喋ってもいいんだけど
嘘を言うなと 喋ってもいいんだけど
悪口は言ってはいけないんだと
ですから喋ってもいいんだけど
真実を喋ろうと 人のいいとこを喋りましょうと
で 噂っていうのは人の仲が悪くする言葉ですね
ですから喋ってもいいんだけど
噂を言うのはとなすならば
お互いに調和がなくなりますから
で 喋るんだったらお互いに仲良くするような言葉を喋りなさいと
で そのようにまあ行為を道徳的に分けちゃうんですね
体の行為にしたっても
他人の生命に邪魔することはやめた方がいいし
他の生命に自分の幸福になる行動はやった方がいい
例えば種をまくとかね
農業するとか で 自分住んでるところやら住んでる場所やら綺麗にするとか
そういうことで自分も他人もいい気持ちになる
それはいい行動で 人に喧嘩するわ殴るわ蹴るわということは
他人の生命に大変迷惑ですから
それはやめた方がいいと
で そこで出てくるのは人を殴ってやったっても
他人が苦労したってもいいんじゃないかと
別に関係ないんだと やっぱりそこで見えるのは
蹴った人は蹴られちゃうんでしょうし
殴った人は確実に殴られるし
そういうこと見えてくるんですね
そこで悪いことをしたら
本人に悪い結果が回ってくるということが出てくるんです
で 田中さんが例えばいいことをしましたとする
そうするともう山田さんを褒めることは世の中でないんです
田中さんが人を助けた
助けたんですよ だからだから山田さんが素晴らしい人ですよという人はいません
田中さんが人を助けたんだから
田中さんが素晴らしい人ですよっていうことになるんです
はい たまにいるんですね
世の中で人々がいいことをすると
なんか関係ない人が自分で威張っちゃうんですね
どうだいと そんなの関係ないんです
自分がやらなきゃ それにはこの仏教でストーリーがありまして
帝釈天のあの帝釈天が昔この人間でいた時
随分社会福祉活動していたんです
その社会福祉活動したことで
天国にこの 第2番目の天国なんですけど
そこで王様として生まれたんです
で 彼に奥さん二人いたんです
で 一人がすごいかわいくて
まあ気に入りなんですけど
まあもう一人の奥さんが一生懸命帝釈天のこの天の福祉活動にあの応援するんです
自分で行って 自分も参加して
一生懸命夫婦でもう人々を助けてあげる
この気に入り奥さんがどうせ美人でしょうと思いますけど
全然もう家を出ようともしない
すごく威張って俺の旦那がやってるんだから
まあそれでいいと 自分が威張るだけ
で そこでこう人々が死んじゃって
もう帝釈天として生まれたでしょうし
自分とずっと一緒に社会福祉活動した奥さんも亡くなって
その天国に戻ったんですね
そしたらまあ一緒に天国でも夫婦なんです
それで二人いたんだから
もう一人はなんで来ないかと帝釈天待ってるんです
人間で死んで まあどうせ男は先に死ぬんだから
まあまあ 次に奥さんも死んで天国に来るまで待ってるんだけど
見たところでもう死んでいるんです
でも天国には来ないんです
それでどこに生まれ変わったかと見ると
どこかにこの白鷺になって生まれてる
鷺ですか 鳥 沼のところにいて
まあ魚やらカエルやら捕って食べてるんですよ
まあそこでなんとかして
なんとかなんとか 後でまあ彼女も天国に行ったっていう風にストーリーは進みますけど
まあそこら辺僕は覚えてないんですけど
で とにかくそこで言いたがっているのはね
自分でやらなきゃ自分には結果が出てこないんだと
奥さんがいいことをしているんだから
それでいいんじゃないかなと旦那さんが怠けていたら
もう別に旦那さんにはその徳が回ってこないんです
旦那さんがやってるんだから
もう私はやらなくてもいいと思ったっても
自分にその徳が回ってこないんですね
徳だけじゃなくて 悪いことでも同じことなんです
旦那さんが悪いことしたんだからって
奥さんにまで地獄に落ちることはまたかえってないし
で 業の働きっていうのは大体そういうふうな働きなんです
ですから この自分がした行為は自分に回ってくると
そこで問題って仏教で考えたら
もうどうやって自分に回ってくるかっていうことなんですね
手でやったことは自分に回るということではないんです
足でやったこと自分に回るんではなくて
なぜ自分に回るかということで
この心の意思でやったんだから
心は 一本通し流れているんだから
もういつかそういう結果が出てくるんだと
で そこで前説明したこの時間の問題
行為はすぐその場で結果出さなくても
後でゆっくりとじわじわと結果出すこともできるんです
で あのお湯を沸かそうと思って
やかんにいっぱい水を入れて
我々は一回だけガスコンロに火をつける
それで 15 分経っちゃうと
もうお湯は沸かしてるんです
15 分間も火をつける必要はないんです
だから水に熱を上げますという一回の行為で
その水は自分の